南江律师你们知道吗？
知道他的扣个1，
喜欢他的也可以扣个1，
因为兰江律师这个人啊，
坦率的说啊，
我发自内心的很尊敬他，
为什么尊敬他？
因为他是咱们中国的律师证和美国的律师证，
他是持双证上岗的人，
你要持双证上岗有多难，
考一个美国的律师证可太难了，
我也经常就会看南江律师的切片呀，
看南江律师的直播呀，
他情绪稳定到根本不像他这个年纪的人该有的状态，
你们有没有这种感觉？
而且他多才多艺，
又会唱歌，
关键是什么呢？
他知识面非常的丰富，
他不光是懂婚姻这方面，
情感这方面，
他还懂刑法那方面的，
还懂各种各样的其他的法律知识，
所以他的知识面比龙飞的知识面要宽广个3~5倍吧，
我是这么觉得的，
然后蓝江律师他自己写了一本书，
这本书呢我也看了，
咱实话实说啊，
你要是说天天跟龙飞在一块的话，
你只能学一点婚姻啊，
家庭啊，
怎么分财产啊，
怎么争孩子啊，
只能学点这些知识。
但如果你看兰江律师的书的话，
你能学到更多的知识，
比如说刚开始在一起的时候，
半推半就或者强迫了，
然后后面又愿意跟他在一起发生关系了，
那么这种情况下构不构成犯罪？
比如说谈恋爱的时候，
让他给你买这个买那个，
构不构成诈骗，
你不想跟他谈恋爱了，
就比如说打赏的那些。
东西有没有构成诈骗的这种可能性啊，
等等等等，
就是他知识面很广，
它里面也都是案例，
通过案例来给大家讲法律的知识，
我个人认为啊，
所有的龙飞姐的朋友们啊，
都可以人手一本买回去看，
就是多学一点这方面的知识，
是不吃亏，
不上当，
不受骗，
如果我们真的遇到了这样的情况的话，
也有一个支撑，
有一个底气。
姐妹们如果说对自己的人生啊，
想要拓展一下法律这方面的知识的姐妹们，
就可以去看一下蓝江律师写的这本书，
这是他的相当于开山之作，
第一本书大家可以去试一下啊，
兰江律师就会手把手的教你怎么去保护自己的利益，
怎么能够让自己在一段亲密关系当中，
经济上不受损失，
身体上不遭遇意外的这种伤害，
这本书真的值得所有的，
不管是男孩子女孩子，
不管是十五六岁情窦初开，
还是说二十几岁正在谈恋爱，
正在谈婚论嫁，
都值得你们去学习一下，
去看一下啊。